i remembered going to a class that you
taught where you mentioned
every 16 iq points a woman goes up from
a hundred she's
40 percent less likely to get married
and every 16 iq points a man goes up
from 100 he's 35
more likely to get married i remember
hearing that i was sitting in on one of
your classes because i don't know why
maybe it was summertime or something or
i wasn't going probably a punishment i'd
arranged for you
it probably was anyway i was there and i
remember hearing that and being like
this is bad
this is bad news i don't know and this
is pure speculation but
i don't think it's unreasonable to point
out that pursuing a career
and a family is more difficult for women
than it is for men i think that's
because of the
differential commitment during pregnancy
and for the first couple of years
it might be that more intelligent women
have a harder time because they have a
broader range of interests and perhaps
of abilities
it's less obvious to them how to
reconcile that with
the more traditional maternal role i i
don't know and speculation